what the player formerly known as most
caucuses what do you think the role of
psychedelics will be in the future
marijuana will most likely be somewhat
legal everywhere in the US and this may
push someone to try stronger
psychedelics is this bad let's start
with the first one I have no idea what
the role of psychedelics will be in the
future I know that the FDA just cleared
ecstasy for use for post-traumatic
stress disorder so that's very
interesting I know there's some very
interesting work being done at Johns
Hopkins on psilocybin mushrooms which
seem to be very effective for example in
helping people stop smoking I think that
we don't know anything about
psychedelics at all I mean we know that
they seem to have an effect on the
serotonin system but that's a pretty
broad brushstroke
I think there incalculably peculiar and
that they reveal things about the
structure of the world that we are
beyond ignorant about beyond a word I
have no idea what role they'll play in
the future I don't know what to think
about psychedelics at all
marijuana will most likely be somewhat
legal everywhere in the US and this may
push some to try stronger psychedelics
is this bad I suppose it depends on how
they're used whether or not it's bad and
what the intent is I think there are
very bad party drugs you know
psychedelics aren't aren't for fun I
don't think that that's the right way to
use them at all I think they need to be
used seriously and they need to be used
in a manner that's life-affirming
and they need to be used in a manner
that's commensurate with genuine
exploration and they need to be used
carefully or they can cause a lot of
trouble so Carl Jung said beware of
unearth wisdom and I think that's very
wise so anyways I hope that we continue
investigating them scientifically
because there's much to be learned there
much more than we can imagine as far as
I'm concerned